as we were just discussing covert case
numbers are on the rise but it's as yet
unclear whether the link between cases
and serious illness and death
has been broken or just weakened one
person who might be able to shed some
light on this is the man who understands
the data as well as anybody
the national statistician sir ian
diamond who joins
us now
um syrian you're the national
stato in today's lexicon and one of the
measures that you keep an eye on is the
prevalence
of antibodies whether they come into us
by
vaccination or by infection
um but it's a sign of how close we are
to this thing
that people talk about herd immunity how
do you think we're doing right now on
that
as i said trevor good morning it's
lovely to see you um i have to say
that i think uh with regards to
antibodies
we are uh doing very very well i'd have
to say that
uh antibodies aren't a perfect
protection
but at the same time we're saying very
clearly that we think
uh that about nine in ten people
uh in england in wales and in northern
ireland about eight 1810
in scotland uh do uh
have antibodies at the moment and let's
be fair that's up from two in ten
in um in in january so
i think that is an enormous uh increase
um i have to say the
the the group with the lowest um at
around about 60 percent
is um those age uh
15 to 24. so um clearly
the vaccination program that the
minister was just talking about
remains incredibly important uh but
certainly we're making
an enormous amount of progress and
absolutely admirable amount of progress
okay so we're moving along though we've
got some work to do with younger people
one of the uh issues where there's
uncertainty
is about the relationship between the
average number of contacts
that an infected person has and the
likely
uh probability of uh of infection
and based on what we've seen previously
um
at the moment they're talking about two
infections
per infected person as it were um based
on what we've seen before how many
contacts do you think each positive case
is likely
to be having uh in the next period
i i mean i mean trevor it that's an
incredibly difficult to me it's almost
an impossible question
um because i don't need to talk to you
about distributions and i don't need to
talk to you about
the the the challenge uh of looking at i
should also say
um that you know it really does
depend uh on uh the contact professor
cut notes at least university has spoken
eloquently
about different uh types of contacts and
how
you you could um get a contact but you'd
be so
unlucky just from walking past someone
as opposed
to uh very close contact in
in a crowded space so i just think the
numbers don't talk about the context and
it would be wrong to answer that
okay but um do you think that the health
secretary's
uh estimate it's not an estimate but his
uh
upper um projection if you like
of a hundred thousand in uh infections a
day do you think that's credible
well i think what we're seeing at the
moment uh and
let me be clear we are keeping an
absolutely
close uh minute-by-minute eye on
the the number of uh infections that we
are seeing in our very very large survey
which
which does give us you know some of the
best data in the world because let's
remember
uh many people uh who who do get the
virus are
asymptomatic and those data will
continue to be incredibly important and
i thank everybody
who who takes part of them what we are
seeing
is yes uh an increase so our most recent
data
uh for for england um as uh
as an about one inch 160 people that's
about 0.6 of a percent
now that's going up quite quickly
having said that it's still less than
slightly less than a third of where we
were on the 2nd of january
this year scotland is a bit higher
um although the numbers of infections
seem to be flattening
a little um in um so
look sure the numbers are going up
they're driven
largely i would have to say by at the
moment the big increases in the
northeast
the northwest had big increases and is
at the same levels of the northeast it's
a
slight trend towards a flattening there
and things are very much lower with the
lowest levels in the east of england
than the southeast of england
so at the moment definitely an increase
driven by
uh at the moment largely the northeast
and driven very much
uh by people uh aged 18 to
24 we're seeing very very little
uh increase um in people
uh age um over 50 for example
and i think that's that that's
encouraging so i i'm not going to do
murder with
projections into the future but i'd have
to say the projections into the future
uh have very large confidence intervals
uh associated with them
but you don't rule out the possibility
of a hundred thousand a day
well i don't think i think it would be
wrong to to completely
rule it out but i would have to say that
at the moment we don't have the data
either uh really to to put a
firm number on things but we are seeing
a a steady uh and fast increase in the
northeast
steady increases uh elsewhere as i say
no increases in the southeast and the
east of england
underlying the judgments that the
government has to make
uh which are not your judgment i
understand that you're not in this field
but
underlying it is um a view about whether
the link between infection and
hospitalization
and serious disease and death has
truly been broken now you know
in the stats word we'd be talking about
random relationships and all that but
you know in simple terms where do you
stand on this do you
think that link has effectively been
broken or not
well i'm i i'm in the severely weakened
uh
the very simple reason that we need to
continue
tirelessly to look at the data uh and
we are at the if you like the the
beginning
uh at the moment um of looking at this
uh and all the evidence as the taxi
minister just said to you
uh is that that we have a younger uh
cohort of people being hospitalized at
the moment and
while hospitalizations are going up uh
they
are now uh a long way fro from some of
the levels
we have seen uh before and
so i'm very hopeful that we have
really made a strong um
break but at the same time um
i would have to say at the moment all
the evidence allows me to say severely
weakened
taking all of this to together and i
want to ask you about a particular
event as a sort of example of
judgment that has to be made um next
month
manchester united play leads first game
of the season 14th of august 75
000 people at old trafford now um
were you to be offered uh a ticket for
that
game would you be going along
to spend the afternoon 75 000 people
most of who would not be wearing masks
uh given levels of compliance
what would you what would you advise
well trevor i spent a long time first of
all if it was you who
was offering me the ticket trying to
swap it for one at talker united
[Laughter]
having said that a couple of points you
made
you know why is it that
uh you say that not many people would be
wearing masks
we are seeing from our our our data
our opinions and lifestyle survey that
um
the great majority of people are saying
they would
continue to wear masks in crowded places
where i'd be going i would be wearing a
mask so
i mean i think i think you know we have
to think very carefully
um about we're making those
uh kind uh of assumptions
um and you know and i do think
um that again people will be making
decisions
uh on the basis of what they see uh the
risk
at that time uh and i'm sure the great
majority of people
would be looking at um both both
that risk and what the risks were before
taking the final decision
okay so you're probably the most
statistically
literate guest uh that we've ever had
on this program statistically speaking
what's gonna happen tonight oh
well look i've been saying uh to anyone
who will ask one one after extra time
and we will win on penalties
penalties okay uh
okay he's coming home trevor
[Laughter]
you've actually anticipated my question
thank you so england win on penalties
no question you heard it here first
sorian thank you very much indeed